welcome back to deepmind the podcast
with me hannah fry in this series i've
been meeting the people who are hard at
work on the technologies of the future
and whenever i talk to people here it
usually isn't long before they mention
three magic letters
a lot of discussions at deepmind end
with how are you defining agi on the
path to agi we will create fabulous
technologies what if the application
that we want to solve is agi agi ati
agi
which stands for artificial general
intelligence
it's the ultimate aim that drives so
much of deep mind's work
like other abstract ideas love justice
success it means something slightly
different depending on who you ask
for some agi signifies a human level
general intelligence
others in the field are more dismissive
of agi
one notable researcher likened a belief
in agi to a belief in magic
in previous episodes we've explored some
of the tangible stuff capabilities such
as language cooperation and physical
intelligence that researchers believe
could help take us towards agi
but in this episode i want to spend some
time digging into what's meant by agi
itself
what actually is it
what will it look or feel or sound like
what will it accomplish
is a future with adi even desirable and
if so what is the best way of getting
there if indeed there is only one way
lots and lots to answer in this episode
five
the road to agi
if anyone can lay claim on defining agi
it is deepmind's co-founder and chief
scientist shane legge
back in the halcyon days of the dot-com
boom shane worked at a new york startup
called webmind where they were
attempting to create human level
intelligence on the internet
webmind's founder was the ai researcher
ben gertzel and when almost a decade
later gertzl was compiling a book of
essays about ai that could excel beyond
a few narrow tasks
shane put forward a title i suggested to
him well we're interested in powerful
ais that are really general we should
just call artificial general
intelligence agi
and so i proposed that to him and he put
that as the title of his book and it
sort of caught on after that
that same year in 2007 shane elaborated
on the concept further in a famous paper
he defined intelligence as an agent's
ability to achieve goals in a wide range
of environments
would you make any modifications today i
wouldn't modify it but i
would look at adding and extending the
question is how do you go from this
super general theoretical notion to
something that's
more like intelligence in the world that
we happen to live in and maybe like more
like say human intelligence in that
world
but for shane agi won't simply be a
replication of human intelligence inside
a machine
i think there are levels of generality
and capabilities beyond what humans have
and you know that shouldn't be
surprising to us i mean you know birds
might fly fast but you know machines can
fly faster elephants can lift heavy
things with their trunks but you know a
crane can lift something much easier so
i i do expect that there will be
machines that will be able to
know more remember more reason more
deeply than humans it's a tantalizing
prospect an intelligent versatile
problem-solving system called agi that
does the things humans can only better
but if that sounds like science fiction
to you
well you wouldn't be the only one
if you go back 10 12 years ago the whole
notion of agi was
lunatic friendship people would
literally roll their eyes
and just walk away you had that happen
yeah multiple times
yeah people you respected yeah people in
the field would just literally roll
their eyes and just walk away have you
had the chance to meet them since um i
have met quite a few of them since there
have even been cases where some of these
people applied for jobs and deep mind
years later but yeah it was a field
where
you know there were little bits of
progress happening here and there but
powerful agi and rapid progress seemed
like it was very very far away
but given the rapid progress in ai over
the past 10 years in everything from
understanding biology to the game of go
for some at least agi no longer seems
such an outlandish idea do people still
roll their eyes
every year it becomes lease
for over 20 years shane has been quietly
making predictions of when he expects to
see agi
always felt that somewhere around 20
30-ish it was about 50-50 chance
i still feel that seems reasonable if
you look at the amazing progress in the
last 10 years and you imagine in the
next 10 years we have something
comparable maybe there's some chance
that we will have an agi in a decade and
if not in a decade well i don't know say
three decades or so
and what do you think it will look like
it could take many forms because by
definition the g in agi is about
generality you can deal with language it
can reason it could do some mathematics
it can program computers it could write
some poetry and it could take multiple
different forms it could be a service
that you go to sort of like a google or
something where you can consult the ai
system about something it could be
embodied in a robot at some point in the
future
or it could be say in the fabric of a
city and it could be something that many
different people interact with at the
same time
but if aji could take a variety of forms
how will shane recognize it when he sees
it for the first time
what i imagine is some sort of simulated
3d environment or something rather and
being able to
talk to the agent the agent can talk
back and really
seeing that the agent is able to
solve novel problems that it hasn't seen
before to a level that is comparable to
that of a human and so it's about that
ability to use its understanding of its
world and its previous experiences with
other problems and draw parallels and
analogies with other things
that to me will be the point at which i
go okay maybe we have an agi here
you'll notice that what shane is
describing is an adi in simulation as a
poster in real life
and you might be wondering does that
count
some people won't accept that
until it's actually running around the
real world i think simulated
environments can be made sufficiently
complex
that the ability to solve novel problems
that the agent hasn't seen before
in fairly rich simulated environments i
think that'll be enough
and then we'll be able to cross the
barrier to real world and we know some
of the algorithms that we use work in
the real world so a lot of the vision
algorithms a lot of control algorithms
can control real robots and so on some
of those aspects that you described as
expecting an agi to have so language and
embodied intelligence there are really
sophisticated agents that can do each of
those already is that the route to agi
do you think
there are algorithms that can do very
particular things but doing them
together in a really coordinated way
seems to be a lot harder there seems to
be something missing around
the ability for algorithms to generalize
in
quite deep ways that you might regard as
conceptual
so an algorithm can see a pattern in
some data where people with certain
results in their blood tend to have a
disease versus not have a disease and so
on and they can even go further than
that to things like
recognizing
you know dogs versus cats where they
fall down though is when you have
something that's more abstract and
conceptual in nature
they tend to do somewhat simple
generalization over vast vast amounts of
data
and the result is very effective but if
you really try to push them to
generalize in some way that's outside of
any data they will have seen often it's
something that a human can do but they
can't do
we'll be exploring agi further including
the biggest opportunities and dangers of
this technology in our final episode
when i sit down with deepmind ceo demus
asabus
for now though a group of researchers
think they have found a pathway that
could eventually lead all the way to agi
remember this
alphago became the first computer
champion at the game of go and it was
the major result for artificial
intelligence and you won the sweepstake
and i won the sweepstake
in season one we told a story that has
now become something of an ai legend in
2016 a worldwide audience of over 200
million people watched as a deepmind
system called alphago beat human world
champion lisa doll at the notoriously
difficult board game of go
the machine learning technique on which
alphago was based is known as
reinforcement learning and we've already
met it several times in this season it's
the same idea that's being used to train
ais to cooperate with each other and
robots to walk around
but david silva the principal scientist
behind alphago whose voice you heard in
the clip just there believes the
technique could prove even more powerful
still
in the last few years reinforcement
learning has come of age to something
which is really starting to see at scale
applications in the real world as a
result people are ready to take
seriously the potential of reinforcement
learning to really grapple with some of
the big questions of ai
to recap reinforcement learning is
distinct from the other main types of
machine learning out there namely
supervised learning where there's a
teacher that tells the machine what to
do it says this is the right thing to do
in this situation and then the machine
has to try and replicate that decision
those mildly annoying i am not a robot
test so you have to complete online are
an example of supervised learning
every time you identify a traffic light
or a motorbike in an image you're
helping to train an image recognition
algorithm to classify those types of
images automatically
then there's
unsupervised learning where there's no
feedback at all from human and what the
system can do is to kind of figure out
patterns in its data but it doesn't
really know what to do with those
patterns it doesn't give it a goal or
any kind of feedback whatsoever
a quintessential example of unsupervised
learning is
clustering like the algorithms that
group photographs according to type
photos taken in nature or a party or a
sporting event say
and then there's reinforcement learning
the human gives feedback
saying good or bad
in the form of reward so
the goal of reinforcement learning is to
try and maximize this reward signal
this reward signal is just a positive
number a plus one which tells the
algorithm that the action it has just
performed is conducive to its overall
goal
[Music]
during a precup a renowned researcher
who specializes in this technique
explained to me how she made use of it
in her everyday life
i remember when our kids were young we
were trying to get them to pick up their
toys and put them in the toy chest
and so we instituted a reward system by
which there was a special treat
a small chocolate if they picked up
their toys and so i think we can
actually train very complex behaviors by
using these rewards
we'll come back to joyner's ai based
life hacks and some of the pitfalls with
reward training a little bit later on
but back to the machines
so far deepmind has created lots of
individual reinforcement learning agents
that specialize in particular domains
such as alphago in the game of go
but now they're starting to develop more
multi-purpose reinforcement learning
agents
after the history-making match against
lisa dole the next step for the team was
to build alpha zero another board game
player but one that learnt by playing
different versions of itself
rather than being trained on data from
professional matches
and then
deepmind built mu0
[Music]
what we did in mu0 was we asked what if
our agent is approaching some completely
new environment like a game it's never
seen before and it just has to figure
out the rules of the game for itself
and in doing so understand it's its
environment in a sufficiently powerful
way that it can actually succeed in
winning the game or in achieving its
rewards in the real world
an ai that can pick up the rules of the
game for itself could in theory excel at
any new gaming scenarios
but crucially as we'll find out later in
this episode could be thrown into a real
world situation and teach itself how to
be successful
when it was tested out on the games of
go chess and shogi
mu zero achieved superhuman performance
despite never seeing the rules of the
game
each time we take away a bit of
knowledge from the system we provide it
with a new opportunity for it to
actually learn and figure out something
for itself that's so mad that everything
we tell it we're just getting in the way
that's right
now it's one thing for a reinforcement
learning algorithm or agent to teach
itself the relatively fixed rules of a
board game like chess or go
but it's quite another for it to figure
out the rules that govern the messy real
world that we live in
if you just think of a simple example
we've got an agent and it's going out
into the rain and it wants to know how
to keep dry if we try to describe to our
agent the pattern by which raindrops
fall and all the other complexities of
its world we're quickly just going to
become unstuck
if you want to build an agent that aims
to stay dry it would be extremely
difficult to build an entire model of
its environment the water cycle
atmospheric circulation historic
precipitation data etc
instead mu zero zeros in on the things
that really matter to achieve its aim
maybe the agent needs to understand that
if it puts its umbrella up that will
keep it dry but it doesn't need to
understand the pattern of raindrops that
fall on top of the umbrella
i guess the agent also needs to know
that if it's really gale force winds and
it tries to use an umbrella then it
won't work to stop it from getting wet
and maybe a raymac would be better
it's part of the idea here that there's
nuance in the real world and that by
instructing agents on what to do you're
kind of trampling over any of that
opportunity for subtle understandings
that are context specific exactly
rather than getting a total
understanding of what's going on around
it muzero just focuses on the bits that
are really important for planning ahead
how good is its current position how
good was the last action it took at
achieving its aim and which action is
the best to take next
it doesn't matter if the system builds a
model of the world which is completely
crazy you know maybe it thinks that
raindrops magically appear and make the
umbrella wet that would be fine as long
as it gets everything right in terms of
the three quantities we care about
mu0 is more than just an algorithm that
knows when to step outside with an
umbrella
david and his colleagues believe it
could also be a milestone on the way to
agi
last year david co-authored a
provocatively titled paper called reward
is enough
he believes reinforcement learning alone
could lead all the way to artificial
general intelligence
we're really arguing that all of the
abilities of intelligence from
perception to knowledge to social
intelligence to language can be
understood as a single process
of trying to increase the rewards that
that agent gets if this hypothesis was
true it would mean that we only need to
solve one problem in intelligence rather
than a thousand different problems for
each of the separate abilities
take the example of a squirrel which in
the pursuit of a single goal collecting
nuts develops lots of different
abilities in the process
even that simple thing requires the
squirrel to acquire some traits of
intelligence
doing a pre-cup is a co-author of the
reward is enough paper
so obviously physical ability to be able
to climb trees to access nuts but also
social intelligence because if a
squirrel is hiding nuts somewhere it
would want to camouflage them from other
squirrels right so it has to reason
about what other squirrels might think
it has to remember where it's put the
nuts and they also have to plan ahead
during the winter there's no nuts and so
the squirrel in the fall in some sense
has to get the nuts ahead of time so all
of these traits of intelligence can
actually come from the squirrel
optimizing a particular reward function
you can see how this nutty reward might
work for things like physical prowess
the squirrel developing its muscles and
becoming more agile as it strives for
the tastiest nuts but what about
something like language
as we've heard in this series current
language models are not based on
reinforcement learning algorithms but on
a different type of neural network known
as a transformer could a reward-based
algorithm work here
essentially yes the hypothesis is the
possibility to actually learn language
in a very different way in the same way
that it would be helpful to learn what
the word duck means because if you
don't duck and a ball hits you or a rock
hits you on the head
you will experience a negative reward or
that you might learn that it's helpful
to ask for help and someone will come to
your assistance and now you might take
that further and imagine that more
sophisticated sentences might lead to
someone actually assisting you in more
complicated ways and helping you to work
collaboratively to farm for food
i was intrigued as to how far david was
willing to push his hypothesis
do you sort of find yourself looking at
your everyday life as goal optimizing
processes and constantly like looking
out for what the reward is that you're
trying to optimize
i've got to come clean i do set myself
goals and say right that's my reward i'm
gonna go for it at the same time i think
the big picture of people you know is a
very messy one that is really hard for
us to explain
our day-to-day actions in terms of oh
right now i'm optimizing this reward i
don't think it's quite like that i think
it's more like there's an overarching
goal for intelligence maybe something
which evolution bestowed our brains to
try and achieve you know maybe we don't
like pain for example and all the rest
of it all these things which from moment
to moment we're trying to achieve
something those are like sub goals
and all of those sub goals we pick like
what am i going to work on next what am
i going to eat for dinner tonight these
are all somehow in service of our
overall evolutionary driven goals what
do you think is the overall goal for
humans
it's a really profound question i mean
philosophers have been asking this since
they dot and
i won't be able to give you a satisfying
answer i suppose in a way i'm sort of
asking you what's the meaning to life
i think you are and that's why it's a
difficult question
well what can i say you come for a
podcast about artificial intelligence
and end up speculating on the meaning of
life you're welcome but we digress
back to the machines again
is this a game changer i guess time will
tell
one of the
stories of ai for the past 60 years or
so
has been that people have made progress
in particular niches right computer
vision has gotten a lot better language
processing has gone a lot better it's
still very very hard to integrate all
these things into one agent but if we
train an agent in one way by maximizing
the reward function
then all of these things might emerge
naturally in one agent and be connected
to each other from the get-go
but not everyone at deepmind is
convinced that reinforcement learning on
its own will be enough for agi
here's ryan hansel director of robotics
the question i usually have is where do
we get that reward from it's hard to
design rewards and it's hard to imagine
a single reward that's
so all-consuming that it would drive
learning everything else
i put this question about the difficulty
of designing an all-powerful reward to
david silva
i actually think this is just slightly
off the mark this question in the sense
that maybe
we can put almost any reward into the
system and if the environment's complex
enough amazing things will happen just
in maximizing that reward maybe we don't
have to solve this what's the right
thing for intelligence to really emerge
at the end of it kind of question and
instead embrace the fact that there are
many forms of intelligence each of which
is optimizing for its own target and
it's okay if we have ais in the future
some of which are trying to control
satellites and some of which are trying
to sail boats and some of which are
trying to win games of chess and they
may all come up with their own abilities
in order to allow that intelligence to
achieve its end as effectively as
possible
the reward is enough paper focuses on a
long-term vision of how reinforcement
learning could lead to agi
but in the shorter term the current
generation of algorithms are far from
perfect
one of the notorious problems with this
technique is known as the credit
assignment problem it's sometimes
difficult for the algorithm to work out
which of its actions led to a particular
reward let's go back to doyner and her
ai life hacks
because of the time lag between joyner's
children tiding away their toys and
receiving their reward and after dinner
treat it took a while for them to make a
connection between being tidy and eating
chocolate and when they did make that
connection they figured out a way to
hack the reward function
they got into this loop where they would
take everything out of the toy chest and
put it back in and then take it all out
and put it back in a pretty clear
indication that the very fast figured
out how to optimize for the signal so we
had to redevise what the signal was in
order to make sure that we didn't get
this kind of behavior
part of the reason for this credit
assignment problem is that current
reinforcement learning algorithms lack a
skill known as temporal abstraction the
ability to consider the potential
repercussions of actions over long
timescales
this is a capability that humans do have
let's say somebody's contemplating going
to graduate school
you really have to compress in your mind
this time period of a few years
and try to understand
what the situation might be at the end
of that you know what might be the
rewards that are going to happen maybe
you'll have a better job and so on
that's a different level of planning
than let's say grocery shopping for next
week
but the algorithm for doing the planning
actually can be the same algorithm and
if you can have it work at a higher
level of abstraction
then actually this problem of forward
planning and also credit assignment over
that long period of time can be solved
no one yet knows the answers here no one
knows how to get to agi or if
reinforcement learning will indeed be
enough
but this is the process of science
hypothesis conjecture experiments and
debate
here's shane leg again
i think in practical terms you're more
likely to make progress in artificial
intelligence by having other kinds of
learning algorithms in there so you
would have some reinforcement learning
going on you'd have some supervised
learning
and other things
there's no doubt that reinforcement
learning is part of the solution i'm
just not sure that it is the only
solution human beings and animals as
well have a lot of different types of
learning that they are doing all the
time and i think it just makes sense
that a learning system would also take
advantage of these different sources of
feedback
[Music]
it's certainly the case that
reinforcement learning algorithms as
they stand are not capable of maximizing
arbitrary rewards in complex
environments
many of the issues that we face they're
hard issues and yet they're not
philosophically intractable issues and
so i do believe that at some point when
communities across the world put our
minds to tackling this problem
we will find the solutions
but of course this is a hypothesis i
cannot offer any guarantee that
reinforcement learning algorithms do
exist which are powerful enough to just
get all the way there and yet the fact
that if we can do it it would provide a
path all the way to agi should be enough
for us to try really really hard
whichever road it takes to get there
there is a palpable belief at deepmind
that artificial general intelligence is
coming down the track sooner rather than
later
and along the way all sorts of new
algorithms will emerge that can be
usefully applied right now to problems
in the real world
remember our friend mu0
you'll recall that what is particularly
special about this reinforcement
learning agent
is that it's earned its stripes winning
games and solving practical problems
jackson brochier is a product manager in
the applied team which specializes in
finding real world uses for ai
real world problems are messy and hard
to explicitly define and so immediate
zero gives us the capability to put an
agent into an environment give it an
explicit goal and it can then plan and
search through that environment to find
optimal strategies to achieve that goal
mu0 works best when a real world problem
shares similarities with the board games
its predecessors were designed for
there needs to be a right answer a way
to win as it were there needs to be lots
and lots of data available for it to
train on
and the algorithm is best suited to
problems with a vast number of possible
moves or actions that it would be
impossible to search through one by one
the question is what kinds of real world
problems might be suitable for such an
ai
one of the applications we've been
looking at is video compression a vast
amount of traffic on the internet is
actually taking the form of video so if
you can actually compress videos more
effectively you can save a huge amount
of traffic and therefore energy and cost
to put this in context it's estimated
that over 80 percent of global internet
traffic is consumed by streaming and
downloading video
that might be a bingeable tv drama a
video call with a colleague an
educational seminar or i don't know
maybe something a bit less high brown
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the point is that whenever someone
uploads a video to the internet the file
gets compressed or encoded to make the
process of sending it more efficient
there's a balance to be struck you want
to compress the video file as much as
you can while losing as little as
possible in terms of quality
the quality of the video is partially
determined by its bit rate the ones and
zeroes that you're using to send that
video across the internet
jackson joined me on a video call
between homeschooling lessons with his
children and here is how he explained it
there's a allowance that you have and
how you can use those bits and the state
of the art has gotten really good at
creating a lot of tricks for
how to use those ones and zeros to send
over the videos so for example if
there's a part of the video that's
constant throughout each section of the
video it can learn to take that section
and save it and reuse it on the other
side where it's sending the video
like now i'm looking at you and you've
got the background of your home school
classroom as it's coming to me the
algorithm would recognize that that
isn't changing frame to frame and just
uses that as a way to make it more
efficient yeah so these jellyfish in the
background they're the jellyfish of a
little while ago not the jellyfish at
this moment and so there's lots of
tricks like this that we can use to make
video encoding very efficient and so
this is where it's framed itself up as a
great reinforcement learning problem
because we can go in and essentially
treat video encoding as a game
this is a strategic game of how to be as
stingy as possible without compromising
video quality if mu0 splurges on bits
for the frames at the start of the video
giving those static jellyfish a really
high resolution say
it might find itself in trouble later if
suddenly there's more action in the
video
mu0 plays this game against itself
thousands of times until it arrives at
the optimum spread of bits
we're seeing a little over six percent
improvement in the bit rate optimization
so that directly correlates to
videos that are six percent smaller
being sent across the internet
a six percent saving might not sound
like a lot but scale that up to the
whole of the internet and it's quite a
significant saving there's potential for
carbon savings in the energy use for
transmitting video and then i think most
exciting of all is the user impacts so
we're actually bringing content to more
people so there's lots of regions where
data is sold at a fixed limit so you use
up your data limit for the day and your
internet shuts off well if you're
watching educational content that's less
of a cost that you're paying it's
especially clear in places like india
and indonesia and emerging markets where
gains here directly relates to increased
content
while the overarching goal of artificial
general intelligence hangs over pretty
much everything that deepmind is working
on
using ai to solve problems in the real
world is a significant focus of
researchers here
over the next episodes we'll be taking a
closer look at how ai technology is
being applied to several problems both
in the science lab
what you're describing here is a
potential step change in all of
healthcare and medicine that is the
implication of truly understanding
biology and in our everyday lives i said
are these the same images they were so
close it was remarkable
[Music]
deepmind the podcast is presented by me
hannah fry and produced by dan hardoon
at whistledown productions
if you're enjoying the series we'd be
grateful if you could rate the podcast
and leave a review
bye for now
you